ってなんです 大変だから
わかったぞと これから悩む必要はなんもないんだと
それでさらに頑張らなくちゃいけなくなれば
今自分という心があるんだから
次にまた心が現れるでしょうに
それで次の一歩瞑想に出てくるんですね
じゃあもうわかった 困る必要はなんもない
私はないと それでも今ここに現象があるんだけど
その現象は次の現象を作っちゃうんだから
それはもうどうしようもないでしょうにと
それでなんで次の現象を作るかと
そこを研究して それは心の問題ですから
そこで残りいろいろ煩悩は順番に消し去っちゃうんです
そこで始めがないんだけど
終わりがあるっていうことになった
それはもう悟る人だけ
ということは ただただ原因は根元から捨てれば終わりますと
だから原因論ですか 因果法則っていうのは大事な話になっちゃう
仏教は因果法則のアメになってしまうと
ずっと全部この今日の話に関係ないことを喋りましたけど
あの えーと 何でしたっけ
結晶っていうのはそういうことで
このエネルギーは次の形を取ると
こちら生命論だから 心がある生命の次元で回転することをやめちゃったら
違う次元で違う形で回転し始めるんです
それは結晶と呼んで それは四種類あるんだと
そこはもう簡単で 一番目はアパーイ・パティサンディ
で 離染結晶 いわゆる地獄ですね
餓鬼道やら畜生やら 畜生ですね
畜生 餓鬼道とあしゅらと地獄という
そういうところに生まれるんだと
それは一つの生まれる場所
もう一つはカーマスガティ
欲染 欲染臭結晶と いわゆるまあ欲っていうのは
見て食べて味わって香り嗅いでいるということで
そういう次元に行くんだと
で カーマスガティという
具体的に言えば この人間の世界はカーマスガティ
天国もカーマスガティ
そういうところに生まれ変わる
生まれ変わるんだ  三番目はルーパ・アヴィチャル・パティサンディ
禅定を作った人々は まあ色界に結晶するんです
で 無色界の禅定した人はアルーパ・アヴィチャル・パティサンディになっちゃうんです
それで終わりです この百三十二ページの十番目に書いているのは
どんな心で地獄の次元に行きますかと
あの心の説明でなんとか心が出ましたね
あれは あの不善意熟 釈迦の推度心
ウパーリボディーはアクサラ・ヴィパータ・ウペッカータ・ハガタ・サンティールナ・チッタンという
あの十八の無因心のセットの中に入ってあったんです
その無因心意熟 無因意熟心で
この低い次元で生まれちゃうんです
人間より低い次元で生まれちゃうんです
ここで何を言ってますかというと
例えば人が死ぬ瞬間の心はあるんですね
死ぬ瞬間の心は生まれた心と同じですけど
それちょっと前の心があるんです
その心に自分がやった悪いこととか
なんか暗い考え方入っちゃったら
それに似ている新しい心が死んだ瞬間にすぐに現れちゃうんです
だから一つなくすこと
なくなることは次のものが生まれる法則だから
ここで死ぬ心が 最後の心が現れたら死ぬということを言うんですね
次にまたここで亡くなったんだから
心がまた現れなくちゃいけないんですね
だから現れるものはちょっと前のことの影響でしょ
だからもう不善意熟心という心生まれるんだと
ですから このもうほとんど決まってるんですね
例えば米は次にどうなるかと
といえば ちょっとわからないんだけど
もし炊いたならばご飯にはなるんですね
板ならば別なものになっちゃうんです
自分がなんて言いますか
この花を植えてるんだったら
米をお花植えてる周りに入れておけばどうなるかというと
土になってしまう ですから
米は次にどうなるかっていうことはそんなに決まってるわけじゃないんです
あれその 一番近い原因によって次のことを決めちゃうんですね
あれは この米自体を機械で潰したならば粉になってしまいます
粉になったら一度もご飯にはまたならないんです
いくら頑張っても 米の粉作ったら
あ これはもちろん米だからご飯作りましょうと
できません まあ他のパンとかね
他の何かお好み焼きとかできるかもしれませんだけど
ご飯は無理 ですから 次の現れが一番近い原因によるんです
だから籾は必ずしも稲になりますから
知れない そんなことは
それをちゃんと もう植えておけば稲になりますけど
皮剥いちゃったらもう米です
そこもちゃんと覚えておかなきゃいけないんです
だから私は次にどこに生まれ変われますかと
そんなことを聞くんじゃなくて
そういう風に科学的に物事を見るんであって
どうなるかわかりませんと
どうやってわかるんですかね
死ぬ瞬間に その時あなたの心
どんな心になりますか教えてくださいと
教えてもらったら 僕ははっきりと言えます
あなたはこういうところに生まれ変わりますと
それもわからないで聞くんだからね
これからどこに生まれ変わりますかと
じゃあまた聞くんです
じゃあ私は過去でどこにいたんですか？と
じゃああなたは生まれた瞬間
どんな心でしたか？教えてください
その心の状態を教えてくれたら
あなた過去でこういうところにいますよってちゃんと言えるんです
そこはわからないんだから
もう まあそれだったら情報足りませんと
アメリカに行って私は人を探してますって探したって見つかるんですかね
ちゃんと情報なければ
どんな地方に どんな場所に住んでる
どんな名前の人かということがあったら
もうアメリカであろうとも
中国であろうか アジアだろうが探せますよ
一番近い原因がないと探せません
で そこでこの地獄に行く人々の場合は
もう法則性はちゃんと決まってあって
まあ例えばいろんな悪いことをしていたんで
悪いことをするとどうせ心が暗くなっちゃうんですね
そこで死ぬ時の最後のチッタイティ
この ありますね そこであの即業心が生まれますから
あれはエネルギーの心なんですね
で 悪いことを思い浮かんだら
即業心はどうしても暗いんです
即業心が終わった瞬間で死んじゃう
そこで その即業心にふさわしい心がすぐにまた現れちゃう
だから 別々に この生まれた心と人の生きてた時の心を比べちゃうと
これは本人同じ人とわからないぐらい違うんです
そうすると違う人やと勘違いするかもしれませんだけど
近寄って近寄って一番近い原因見ると
あ 同じ流れだと見えるんです
ですから まあ大雑把に言えば
人が死んで犬になったら
あ これはあのうちにいた田中さんですよとは絶対わかりません
その時はもう正真正銘の犬なんです
でも 犬の性格をどんどん
いろいろいろいろいろいろ見て見て見て見て見て
本来の心のね 方向性なんか見ると
あれなんか田中さん似てるんだ
[笑い]ということはわかる可能性はあるんです
そういう風にこの輪廻転生のことはあの
きちんと一本の流れで流れますけどね
普通の人間にはそれは理解できるものではないということになっています
まあとにかく地獄に行く
生まれ変わる場合は あの
シャグ クセン イジクセンの
えーとスイドーシン ウペッカアプサラウィパカウペッカサハガタンサンティーラナチッタンという心で生まれるんです
ですから 心のエネルギーとしては
大体地獄の次元はみんな大体は同じですけど
でもやっぱりその人の次元によって能力は変わります
犬の能力と猫の能力は違いますからね
同じ次元ですけど ススメの能力とワシの能力と猫の能力もやはりそれ違いますけど
やっぱりそれでも心の次元は同じです
やっぱカーマ・スガティ・パティサンディの場合は
九 なんで九になっちゃう
重たいとなった時に九
この番号の付け方 初め見たんだけど
うん？どういうやり方ですか
じゃあ カーマ・スガティっていうのは人間の世界と神々の世界
そこに生まれる心は あ
これカーマ・スガティ・パティサンディは九種類あるということですね
心は九つあるんです 九つの心で人間でも生まれるし
天国にも生まれるし その九つはどこから出てくるかというと
一つはセン 無因心の中に入っていったセン・イジクシン
スイドーシン シャグーのスイドーシンですね
でもセン・イジクシン
だから無因心だからすごい弱いんです
それですごい弱い心で
人間の世界で生まれる人々は
無因心で生まれた人々になるんです
心がすごく弱くなっちゃうと体も弱い
失礼な言葉になるんだけど
言いなくちゃいけないんだけど
例えば生まれつきすごい障害を持って
知覚障害を持って 人間らしくはちょっと普通の人間らしくは生きていられない
いろんなハンディ持っちゃうと
それは心はもともと弱いですよ
次にこの あの セン・ジクシンでしたっけ
ダイセン・イジクシンでしたっけ
次のところの あ こっち生まれるとこいろいろ書いてるんですね
人間に生まれたらジャッチャンダジーナン
ブッマッシカワナンジャ
で 将来盲目などの人々
だから自身に依視している
これどう読むんですかね
場所のあしら なんか疑惑霊みたいな
ものでしょうね こちらでこの
まあインドでやった信仰と
まあインドだけじゃなくて
あの この この完全に信じてるんですね
神といった途端にちょっと
いいという状態になりますけど
ある場所に定着していて
そこは場所から離れない
で というふうな あの 存在ですね
も そこを生まれるんだと
だから天界のカテゴリーに入るんだけど
神々みたいな自由自在じゃないんです
例えばある ある木に宿ってるんだと
そこで動けませんだから血の中にいなくちゃいけないんですね
人々は木を拝んだり いろいろことして何かお願いしますとか言うかもしれませんだけど
まあ血を誰か切っちゃったら終わりと
神様も死んじゃう で そういうふうにある場所についていたら
まあその場所は離れない
一体になっちゃうんですね
神様  荼毘葬の場合は必ずいるんだけど
神もいるみたいまあ両方いる
そこでマハーヴィパーカ
大いじく心八あります
この大いじく心八 はわかりやすいし
この八の中で四つは二因
四つは三因 それで普通の人間生まれる
それから神々も生まれる
そのところで だから死ぬ瞬間で自分がやったいいことを思い浮かんだら
あ 私もよく頑張って生きてきたんだと
で 自分の人生について
例えば満足感があって
まあ無駄な人生ではなかったと
いいことをできたんだという明るさが生まれたら
もう次は確実に明るいところで生まれ変わっちゃう
明るい心で生まれるんだから
悪いところには行けないんですね
天国が人間の世界になっちゃうんですね
三因で生まれちゃうと
例えば瞑想したり そういう頭がね
智慧が発達する いろんなことをやってきたならば
仏教を勉強することもすごい三因心になっちゃうんです
仏教を勉強すると まあすごいことを勉強しましたっていうことを自分で実感できると思います
人々と話してみてください
普通の人々と このレベルとこちらでお釈迦様が喋っているレベルの差がわかるはずなんです
でも自分たちにそれをなんとか理解できると
もうすごい智慧が発達しているんです
そこで死ぬ時は まあ自分がすごいことをやってきたんだという充実感の心が生まれちゃったら
そこで即興生もなるでしょうね
すぐに三因心で 三縁いじく心で生まれちゃうんですね
で 三縁いじく心でどこに生まれるかっていうことはまたわからない
天国に生まれるか人間に戻るかっていうことはちょっとわかりませんだけどね
大体人間の世界っていうのは生まれ変わる難しい場所だから
あんまり競争激しくてね
なかなかもう生まれ変われないんです
そしたらまあ簡単に天国には行くんです
天国に行くのはもうずいぶん簡単なんです
向こうは人口コントロールとか何もないんだから
何人でもOK 誰が来ても他の神様は神が出てあなたにご飯食ってあげますとか
そういうことないんだから
何もしなくてもいいんだから
だから迷惑にはならない
他の人がいて全く迷惑にならないんだったら
いないよりはいた方がいいんですね
たくさん そういうことで
天界っていうのはいくらでも人々が
生命が生まれ変わること可能な次元なんです
人間の次元は天国よりはちょっと幸福はないんだけど
ものすごい難しい だからまあ
で 人間でも三因で生まれたらものすごい立派な人間になる
性格は素晴らしくて 明るくて
すごく知恵があって 知識があって
やることはもう結構成功するし
で ものすごい人格があって素晴らしい人になっちゃう
で ほとんどの人々は二因で生まれちゃうんです
人間の中で それから寿命のこと
ものすごいできるだけこれ早くサッサッサッと終わりたいんだけど
で あの まあ簡単に言いますと
難しくないです 寿命 寿命っていうのは
ここに寿量と書いてます
まあ寿量でいいかもしれませんけど
あるところで生まれたら
どれぐらいそこでその同じ形で流れて死ぬかってことなんですね
だから ある次元で生まれたら大体似てる形で
例えば人間で生まれたら
まあ形は変わるんだけど
我々は同じと思っちゃうでしょうしね
生まれた胎児と胎児と人間ってのは全く違うでしょうに
赤ちゃんと我々はまた違うでしょうに
我々の若い時と今は全く違うでしょうし
死ぬ時は全く違うんだけど
まあ一応人間ですよってことで
まあ大雑把にまとめちゃうんです
そういう風にある次元で生まれたら
どれぐらいその形で続けるかっていうことは寿量なんですね
まあ一般的に言えば寿命ですね
そこで地獄と人間の寿命は比較して言えないんだ
サトゥンマンアパーヤナンマヌッサナンチャヴィニパティカアスラーナ
さすが定まれないんですね
で 定まらないんですからね
バラバラということで
まあそれなりに寿命を持ってるんですね
例えば神と神が何か あの
なんかこのヴィニパティカするこのダショアスラっていうのは
なんかこの天国からこの罰を受けて
なんか刑務所にいるような感じもしますけど
刑務所の中でもこの あの
厳しく あの ポリス 小部屋
何て言うのか 部屋に入れちゃって
もう もう独房に入れちゃって
すごい厳しく罰せられる時もありますからね
その人は外にも出せませんし
ご飯だけ入れてあげる
で たまにもう光も当たらないと暗いところに入れちゃって
これ 1週間  2週間と決めたりとか
そういう風に まあ感じにもよりますけど
で 神の場合 例えば神はそういう状態になって木に宿ってるんだと思ったら
どれぐらい寿命があるかというとわからない
もう誰かそれを切っちゃいます
切っちゃいますから もう
わからなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば動物の寿命はどうですか
例えばそれぞれの動物は自分自分の寿命を持ってるんですね
鶴は万年ですかね まあ亀
鶴は千年 万年だよ 亀 ですから
この これガラパゴス島の亀だけなんですけど
やっぱり亀 すごい寿命長いんですね
だからダーウィンさんが見たゾウガメは今もありますから
長いこと長い寿命知らないんで
ゾウガメはどれぐらいかと
で まあそういうことでわからないと
人間の寿命もこれぐらいということはないんですね
早く死ぬ時もあるし この時代によって寿命が変わる時もあるし
寿命はそれの天国とかそういうところに行ったら
このいろんなややこしい原因はどんどん減らしますからね
で 寿命は決められるんですね
チャートマハラジカナンバデヴァナンディッバヌパンチャヴァササカーンアユッマナマヌッサガナナーヤナウティヴァッササタサハッサーマナ
これ計算機出るんだから
もうそれでいいわ じゃあ
じゃあそこは決まると
チャートマハラジカっていうのは
あの まあ天国はもう六
六つあります あ そこはありますね
6つあります ですからその一番下の天国ですね
じゃあ四天王の天国 四代王天宮
二百年ですね 人間の年で九百万年
それとこの計算の式じゃないんですが
式っていうか式があるんです
まあこちらなんか昔のスリランカのあるいはバカの
これこちらの四代王天宮の寿命という説明にこの式が入ってるんで
で 人間の五十年 四代王天の一日に相当すると
そこで一日が三十日で
一ヶ月 十二ヶ月と一年で
このような二百年であると
またそれからまたそれで計算する
四代王天の一ヶ月は人間の千五百年
一年は万八千二百 それから二百年ならば九百万年ですね
まあそういうふうに寿命があるということで
まあ天国の年代でいえば二百年生きられると
人間でいえば九百万年
よく長生き長生きするもんですね
でも四代天王も恐竜は見たことないでしょ
だから神に聞いたってわからないだろうね
見たことないんだから
恐竜とか 百万年だから
九百万年だからね で 神が人間
地球で人間はどのように出てきたんですか？どのように現れたんですか？と四代天王の神々に聞いてもわからない
もう寿命が短いんです
で それより僕は面白く言うのは
この 人間のあの五百年っていうのは一日でしょ
そこでみんな神様にお祈りするんですね
で 私たちは問題があると
神様お願いしますと言っちゃうんです
で 人間の寿命 例えば一般的に五百年と言えばね
大体一日 神様から見れば一日何回こいつお願いするんですかと
だから もし朝晩も神様にお祈りすることになっちゃったら
神様から見れば これもう他の仕事できなくなっちゃうんですね
止まることなくお願いしてるんだから
神様もちょっと遊んだり
ちょこちょこ遊んだり
みんなと会議やったりとか
いろいろ仕事はあるし
だから私は言うのはもうお願いしたっても聞いてくれないんだと
自分のことは自分でやりなさいと
なんで神様 私のこんな不公平なこと見てくれませんかと
見てくれませんからね
向こうは向こうで忙しいし
あるいは我々の誰かが天国に生まれたとします
その人はせっかく天国に生まれたんだから
じゃあ自分の孫たちにでもね
まあいいことをしなさい
私は天国に生まれたんですよと言おうとしたっても
じゃああの辺に行ってやろうかと思ったら
もうここにいないんですね
誰も 天国で一日二日間そういう登録したり
いろいろありますし まあ大体そういうシステムあるんです
社会制度ですからね で
そちらのいろいろ仕事終わって
じゃあ人間で 人間でいて
私は天国に来たんだからね
まあみんなのこともちょっとなんか言ってあげた方がいいかなかなと思っちゃうと
もうこちらでもう百五十年
まあ例えば三日目で 三日目では考えられませんだけど
私たちも外国に行ったっても
じゃあうちに手紙でも書こうと思ったのは
まあまあ 僕はもう来てから一度も長老に手紙書いてないんだからね
そのうち書きますと八月になりますから
そんなもんですからね
まあせいぜい家族だったらね
それでも一日二日経ったところで書くんだから
飛行機の中で手紙書くバカもいるんだけどね
まあ今飛行機に乗ってるよ
お母ちゃんとかね で まあちょっと三日休んで
人間の世界見たら誰もいないんですから
もう百五十年経ってるんだから
だからその時の人々に至っても
そんな人はいたか分からないんだと
我々も知りませんでしょ
我々の百五十年前の先祖たちはどんなものかと
だからそんなもんで まああまり
無意味っていうことなんです
結局はね で 三十三天の寿命はあれの倍
五百年だから千年 次には山
ヤーマという天国です
それは二千年 でトソッス天は四千年で
ニンマーネラティという
こちらは楽園天ですね
八千年 タッケジサイ天は千
一万六千年 で そこら辺で終了しましょう
まあここら辺はまあご自分でも読めるしね
私に説明しなくちゃいけないのは
このカッマチャトゥッカというこの四縁起の定義なんです
[背景の雑音]